drawer barnatan is a professor of pure
mathematics at the university of toronto
previously specializing in not theory
and more recently specializing in finite
type invariants and kavanaugh homology
we touch on quantum field theory's
connection to not theory how to learn
mathematics in general we also touch on
ed witton as jorah barnatan's advisor
for his phd was edwitten and drawer
gives some anecdotes about eric
weinstein as while eric was pursuing his
phd drawer served as an informal advisor
to eric at harvard professor barnatan
taught a course in linear algebra that i
took while i was at the university of
toronto although i was a terrible
student and i regret that i skipped the
majority of his classes because he had
an exceedingly intuitive approach for
example there are vector space axioms
can i i do and they seem extremely
disconnected from any reason or
motivation so what the professor would
do would be before introducing a
particular abstraction he would say
imagine seven times a vector instead of
imagine a times a vector and then
generalize it which gave the abstraction
some concreteness for those new to this
channel my name is kurt jaimungal i'm a
filmmaker with a background in math and
physics dedicated to explicating what
are called theories of everything from a
mathematical physics perspective but
also the possible connections
consciousness has to the fundamental
laws of nature provided these laws exist
at all and are knowable to us this
particular podcast isn't one to be
listened to or at least you can but
you're going to be frustrated as what's
being referred to are one-dimensional
objects embedded in a three-dimensional
space in some configuration and the
verbal description leaves much to be
desired if you're listening to this on
spotify or itunes i recommend you click
the link in the description and follow
along you can also download a pdf of the
written notes from this podcast in the
description as well there are a couple
sponsors of today's podcast the first is
algo which is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce returns and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by a
bright individual named amjad hussein
who's been a huge supporter of the
podcast from his early days the second
sponsor is brilliant brilliant
illuminates the soul of mathematics
science and engineering through
bite-sized interactive learning
experiences brilliance courses explore
the laws that shape our world elevating
math and science from something to be
feared to a delightful experience of
guided discovery you can even learn
group theory which is what's being
referred to when you hear that the
standard model is based on u1 cross su-2
cross su-3 visit brilliant.org slash toe
that is t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription i recommend that you at
least try the free trial and don't stop
before four lessons and you'll be
greatly surprised at the ease at which
you can comprehend concepts that you
previously had a difficult time
understanding if you'd like to hear more
conversations like this then do consider
going to patreon.com kurtjimungle
there's also a crypto address and a
paypal address if that's more up your
alley i now do this full time and the
patrons are what allow for me to put out
this content on such a frequent basis
every dollar helps certainly and
regardless i'm grateful for your
viewership again that's patreon.com
kurtjmungle
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l thank you and
enjoy i actually had you as a professor
i believe in linear algebra
i hope you didn't suffer too much
that my favorite aspect of the course
was that you would use the word seven
you give an example of a number so you'd
say a certain field number times a
vector well let's call it seven so seven
times a vector would be so-and-so you
know it can get to extremes right you
may end up doing things like uh
the limit
of uh e to the minus seven uh seven goes
to infinity
uh is equal to whatever it is zero right
anyway yes
what's your field of research
uh not theory
and
from a very algebraic perspective
and
related
algebra things
it used to be
uh
much more not theory and quantum field
theory and it slowly slowly moved to to
being much more algebraic and their
relationship with quantum field theory
became more and more remote
okay what's the relationship let's
forget about the remoteness what's the
close relationship between not theory
and quantum field theory
oh it's a bit hard to
explain and somewhat surprising and
that's why that's why it took a long
time to discover
let me give you
two answers
that are
somewhat unrelated and
one answer is that quantum field theory
is about particles
and
note theory is surprisingly also about
the motion of particles
so
uh you know let's draw a simple minded
knot
uh
so by the way is this a visible
skin yeah okay so here is a simple
minded knot
it's actually the so-called trefoil knot
but uh
well whatever it is
uh now uh what you can do
is you can
uh so it's living in in r3
and uh i could set up my coordinates
so that
uh
this coordinate will be called t maybe
you want to call it z
but you know i like to call it t at uh
right now and the two coordinates here
are x and y
and then i can slice this knot
at
uh equal time
uh slices so basically i uh
draw a plane
which leaves at some fixed height
so at an equal in an equal time plane
and slice the knot and then the slice is
four points
and as i move these points
in time
so as i move the slice in time the
points move
and they actually do a little lovely
dance
and
uh the dance is as follows so if we call
these points uh
a
b
c and d
then they start at a certain position
a b
c and d
right
and then
as i move
uh
well you can see that c and b trade
places so they play a dance they somehow
dance around each other
uh
uh b goes this way and c goes up sorry b
goes
uh one way and c goes the other way and
after a little while they trade places
so you have
a c
sorry a
uh
c b
d
and as you move the plane even further
they trade places again
so
uh again you will have a a b
a c d and if you move a little further
again they trade places so you'll have a
c b d
and then something funny happens
uh
uh
points
uh
well points well by this time this is
point b is over here and point c is over
here
and points a is here and d is here and
what happens is that point c moves
towards point d
and points a more moves to points point
b
and they coincide
and
when they coincide they annihilate each
other because if you look at the plane
which is above
the
the level of the knot
um
uh
you no longer see any point so what
happens next is that these points move
towards each other these points move to
each other they meet and bang they
annihilate and after that there is an
empty set
and in fact i started a tight
uh at a certain height had i started
below i start with the empty set
and instead of annihilation of pairs
you get a creation of pairs so a pair of
points get created here and a pair of
points get created here and then they
perform this nice dance
so this was this particular note but the
same story is true for every note every
note can be written as a certain dance
of points
in which uh sometimes pairs
get created sometimes pair meet and
annihilate each other and in between
these times they all dance
anyway uh
physics in general is about the motion
of particles and it's not too surprising
that there is a relationship
physics also sees things like creation
and annihilation of pairs of particles
and i mean so again it's not so
surprising
but this is very very very loose
and
gee the other explanation i can give you
is even more loose
uh
but even but but in some sense
more
um
closer to the truth
uh well okay maybe you've heard
that quantum mechanics is related to
path integrals
so
uh you know in classical mechanics
uh
you know if a path goes from point a to
point b
sorry if a particle goes from point a to
point b
it goes along a specific path
um
in quantum mechanics it has a
probability of going uh from a to b and
you compute this probability
by doing a certain
integral
over the space of all paths
so the particle or
i mean again even even my interpretation
of quantum mechanics here is a bit loose
because interpreting quantum mechanics
is a very hard thing
but with this loose interpretation you
sum over all probabilities of going this
way or that way or that way
or that way and by adding up all these
probabilities or more precisely
integrating over the space of all of
those probabilities or more precisely
phase factors or
amplitudes
uh you
you can compute the probability of going
from a to b that's quantum mechanics
now
uh
uh likewise quantum field theory but in
quantum field theory it's essentially
the same except the integrals are more
complicated but the point is that
already these integrals
are not like integrals over rn
right rn
is uh the collection of n tuples of
points a1 up to a n
so a point in rn is determined by n
real numbers
whereas a function the space we are
integrating over now
is the space of all functions and a
function
is determined by infinitely many real
values you need to know the value of the
function here the value of the function
here the value of the function here the
value of the function here so to
determine a function you need to know
infinite infinitely many
uh real numbers
so the integral that you end up doing is
not
157 style sorry now i'm using a
toronto style language or it's not one
variable calculus in integral which is
again one variable
uh integral it's not this
it's not second year calculus when you
do n variable
uh integrals
it's infinite dimensional so infinitely
many variables integration this is what
we need
okay
so
uh
quantum field theory
ended up developing
a bag of techniques for computing
infinite dimensional integrals
and what these techniques are is a whole
different story
but uh but quantum field theory ended up
doing this
and then
uh
it turns out
that infinite dimensional integrals are
useful to topology
so so the the the
the way that quantum field theory
becomes useful in topology is indirect
it's not that the quantum field theory
itself
is useful
even this is a lie because sometimes the
quantum field theory itself is useful
but but the main path by which quantum
filter becomes useful to topology
is not
uh
uh direct but a bit indirect quantum
field theory developed a bag of
techniques and this bag of techniques
applies elsewhere
anyway why are infinite dimensional
integrals
useful to topology
um
the answer is again a bit
uh
complicated
but let me try to summarize it
so let me bring a knot here's a knot
okay great
uh
uh well actually that's not a knot
why not picking what i'm showing you is
a curve in r3
a note
is
ah
an equivalence class of such curves so
this is a curve if i deform it a bit
it's still a curve but it's considered
the same knot if i deform it some more
it's still a curve but it con but but
but but it's the same not
so a knot is not a single curve but an
equivalent class of curves
now suppose you want
quantities that are associated to notes
you want to be able to tell notes apart
so you need
quantities
uh that would be computable from the
knot and that you would use them to tell
the notes apart
okay
now it's very easy to compute
quantities
that are associated with curves
so if you have a curve
uh you can measure its how much it bends
so the radius of of the bending
okay again these things have technical
names the curvature maybe the torsion
there are various
names for for various quantities you can
associate with
curves
so you know i can look at the maximal
curvature of this knot of this curve and
the maximal curvature will be the place
where it turns the most and that's
probably around here for this particular
curve around here okay
now um
uh but that quantity is a quantity which
is associated with curves
it's a useless as a quantity for not
it's useless as a quantity for knots
because if we're talking about not you
know i could deform it and the maximal
curvature could go somewhere else
could change could grow could shrink
could differ
right
so the way to get quantities that are
associated
with knots
rather than with
curves
is to integrate over the space of all
geometries
so instead of picking the quantity for a
specific geometric manifestation of the
knot
you integrate over the space of all
geometries and then the result will be a
a quantity associated with the note
unfortunately the examples are very very
hard
so you know the the famous example the
example that uh
got written uh well one of the examples
that got written very very famous in
topology or among mathematicians is the
so-called chern simon's theory
uh or chen simon's quantity which is um
uh so uh in itself some integral so you
integrate over r3
so the quantity itself is a finite
dimensional integral
right so you integrate over r3 something
called the churn simon's form
uh which is something called which is a
wedge d a
plus two thirds
uh
a wedge a wedge a
whatever that is but this is you know
related to stuff appearing in second
year uh multivariable calculus in the
most advanced versions okay so wedge
products and differential forms and
exterior derivatives and stuff like that
then you take this quantity and you
multiply it by i multiply by k
exponentiate it
multiply by another quantity the
so-called holonomy along the note of a
whatever that is so i'm throwing names
because i really have no choice because
giving the precise definition is a
matter for a graduate class yeah okay
and this is the quantity that you
associate with a geometric note
and then to get an invariant of notes or
to get a quantity associated with the
not itself
you integrate it
over the space of all such a's and i
didn't really tell you what these a's
are but it's an infinite dimensional
space
so
uh i guess i haven't really answered
your question by giving an example but i
just told you the examples are hard
okay anyway um
well they're hard but they're exactly of
the nature
that
physics knows how to study
or that quantum field theory developed
techniques
to study and so one can study it using
quantum field theory techniques and get
all sorts of um
well
quantities relevance to not relevant to
not the so-called jones polynomial is an
example and then there are many other
examples
are there any relationships between not
theory and gravity so general relativity
let's say
um
so
i'm not an expert
the answer is yes
uh
but uh but don't ask me to detail it as
i told you i've actually moved away from
that subject
what got you interested in not theory
originally
this subject
so mainly you were interested in physics
well okay i was a math undergrad
uh
but then
during my time as an undergrad and then
a master's student in tel aviv
university i never finished the masters
i moved on to doing my phd in in
princeton but during my time as a
master's student in in
in tel aviv i got more and more
interested in in physics
and
uh there's just wonderful mathematics
inside physics so i got interested in
physics and the fundamental question of
physics right
what are the basic laws of the universe
i mean you can't ask a better question
so i got more and more interested in
physics and decided to do my phd in
mathematical physics
and i ended up uh working with ed
wheaton uh who who is a very famous
physicist or mathematical physicist or
mathematician depending whom you ask
and um
uh and originally my interest was in
physics
or you know
my aim was to do things that was rather
were relevant to physics
somehow that's not what happened you
know at the end you don't choose your
career
sort of the career leads you
you know so uh
i
wrote the thesis which was somewhere in
between math and physics
what was it called
uh what was it called uh perturbative
aspects of the chern simon's quantum
field theory
and that's an approximate title because
i don't exactly remember but then it
turned out that that was relevant to
something called finite type invariants
and i thought i had new things to say
about finite typing variance and that's
completely and not theoretic subject
so
i uh
i
told myself i'll give myself a break
from physics and write a paper or two on
on finite typing variants
and then come back to what i really care
about and that paper or two became 10
years with several paper many papers and
many results and
and
you know
and then a chinese meeting led me to yet
another subject and you know
what was the other subject it led you to
um
well no the next subject after finite
typing variance was juvano homology
anyway you don't choose what you do you
you know you you at most uh try to steer
it
but
it steers you much more than you steer
it
like the subject do you have an
intuitive explanation for people who
let's say they're at the second year
level what is a homology
what's homology
it's a tough
a very tough uh
question
because
it's many things or it's related to many
things
and i could answer it in in many levels
um
you know
uh let me
let me give you a summary answer
sure okay
so
often in mathematics
there are two ways to describe objects
you can describe them implicitly
by telling what equations they satisfy
or
explicitly
by constructing all of them
let me give you the simplest example
so
uh consider
the unit circle
sorry i kind of care about the points of
the unit circle so here is the unit
circle in the x y plane and here is a
point x y
the implicit description of the circle
so the implicit
is
by writing an equation which the points
have to satisfy and everybody knows what
the equation is the equation is x
squared minus sorry plus y squared minus
1 is equal to 0.
okay
uh
but there is also an explicit
description
and again i'm not sure which one is
why the naming is such but it it doesn't
really matter namely i can construct all
the points of the paper of the circle
and the construction is you set x is
equal to
cosine of theta and y is equal to sine
of theta
okay
now this is the general
a general feature in mathematics that
many things can be described either be
constructed that's the explicit
or be defined by an equation
now
if you uh
restrict your attention to linear
algebra
if you you you do the same thing but in
linear algebra
then
uh
the situation is that you have some
space in the middle maybe it's a vector
space
and inside inside that space you want to
describe things
actually i'm not sure why i'm drawing it
curve because the curve because if it's
linear algebra i should be drawing it
straight but anyway you want to describe
things
and there are two ways to describe them
one way
is by saying
these things
well you construct a map into another
space
and you say these things are the things
in the kernel
of this map so i don't know what let's
call this map
fi
and these things
are the kernel of phi
and then
um
so this is the implicit description
this is you describe the things by an
equation and and then there is also the
explicit description so you have yet
another vector space and you have a map
let's call it let's call it psi
and you say the things here
that are
well the good things like the points of
the circle
are the image of psy
so you say these are the things that are
the image of psy
okay and this corresponds to the
explicit view
you construct the things you present
them as an image via some operation
uh
coming from some you know maybe
some smaller dimensional space
okay
uh so
okay
here's a funny thing so
if your construction is reasonable
then everything you construct
solves the equations
in other words everything in the image
of psy
is contained in the kernel of phi
so
once you have a situation like this you
know that you're going to have that the
image of psy
is contained in the kernel of phi
and in fact if you're constructing the
exact same things
then the image of i will be equal
to the kernel of i not just contained
okay and then you will be saying that
the situation is exact
things got exactly the things that
you've constructed are the things that
you described by the equations
but that's not always the case
sometimes you have equations defining
something and you want to know did i
construct all the solutions
so sometimes this inclusion is strict
and then you want to measure
by how much or how much did you fail
so how much did you not construct
everything and that's exactly the
difference between the kernel of phi and
the image of psy and in linear algebra
the difference is quotient so you take
the quotient space
and this is the so-called homology
so somehow homology measures
uh so this measures
uh uh
how
good
are
your
uh constructions
did you construct everything or did you
leave some stuff out
is the kernel the implicit the
description this
does it contain more things and then
you've constructed
so somehow homology measures how good
are your constructions and this is true
in general
uh
and and and then there are lots and lots
and lots and lots of specific examples
uh and
uh
to some extent it's a bit of magic i'm
not sure i i can give you a really good
explanation
why there are so many examples and why
so much of mathematics uh end up
um
having close relationships with with
with uh with homology maybe this is a
partial explanation so
basically you always want to measure how
good is what you've done
so
are you able to talk about what co
homology is and then homology's
relationship to co homology or is that a
whole other can of worms it's another
kind of forms but
in some sense it's not interesting
in in some philosophical sense it's not
interesting
so when i described cohomolo also
it's essentially the same
so
the difference between a homology and
co-homology more than anything else is a
difference of conventions whether your
map goes from left to right or from
right to left
it's it's uh
from this
perspective from this very far away and
very imprecise perspective there's
really no difference
professor what do your average days look
like for example do you wake up at the
same time do you drink the same type of
do you drink coffee and it has to be
this particular type of coffee do you
eat a certain breakfast what does it
look like paint the drawer picture
ah
well i'm a lazy bum
and
i'm a believer in the
um you know there was at some point a
revolution right before that uh people
used to work seven days a week uh 12
hours a day or maybe with a short break
on sunday morning
depending which culture you came from i
suppose
and then at some point there was this uh
workers right uh
uh
revolution
and somehow the working week shrunk to
uh 40 hours a week or so like five days
of eight hours
hours a day right
and i'm essentially a believer in that
uh and furthermore i'm a lazy bum so
during my eight hours of work a day
five days a week i take coffee breaks i
uh
you know browse the web i cheat
uh
um
but anyway you know i wake up at 6 30 i
uh
exercise take a shower have breakfast uh
check my email do all sorts of
unimportant things then uh
around nine usually i start uh working
i work until five or so i'm sorry i'm
very dull
um
and then i try to have fun for the rest
of the day whatever that may be might be
during the pandemic it was it is a bit
harder
and then on the weekends i try to go
biking hiking
puddling
mostly things that don't have to do with
work i'm lying a little bit because
occasionally there is a reason to work
on the weekend and occasionally i do
have a meeting with somebody like i have
an australian collaborator so often our
meetings are in the evenings
so i mean i'm i i've given you an
idealized uh story the truth is a little
different is you know
varies when you're working from nine to
five how much of that time is spent
thinking versus reading someone else's
paper versus answering departmental
emails and requests like what is work
because work obviously for a professor
you have to teach you also have to do
research there's
perhaps 10. work is all of that and it
depends on the season so
basically when i teach two courses
uh so you know
there's basically fall spring and summer
you know fall semester spring semester
and summer okay
in the fall in the spring i teach either
two or one course per semester in the
summer i don't teach
so when i teach two courses per semester
that's
almost
all my attention almost everything i
have
uh goes into that
uh
and the rest goes into the regular
meetings that i have to keep
so i have several graduate students that
i work with several collaborators and
i'm trying to keep weekly meetings with
them
so there is a certain amount of like
weekly meetings that i have to keep
when i teach one course
uh i have some breathing room and when i
teach nothing namely during the summer
then a higher proportion goes into
research
even in the summer the proportion is not
very high
firstly is your ideal situation to
simply be a research professor i know
some professors
don't they treat teaching as an aside
they don't particularly like to do it
i'm curious about your case
well
ideologically
i mean
i see myself as a teacher
um
even the research in some sense
is to support teaching
even the research is so that i will
remain in shape
and
even more so and that the community will
remain in shape so you know if if i do
research i am able to
uh
teach graduate students how to do
research
and then they are
become
stronger mathematicians and can teach
mathematics better so so so so so i even
see researchers mostly uh supporting
uh teaching
so
i definitely wouldn't say that i see
everything as research right i mean
research
again teaching is very significant
well that's the theory
in practice
um
you know waking up every morning and
preparing your class and this marathon
of teaching where you have to prepare
your class
uh you
teach you feel
terrible about the things you missed
during class you don't even have time to
digest it and you have to get ready for
the next class already
so uh
you know
it's very hard
i mean people who haven't done that
don't appreciate how it how hard it is
but it's emotionally very very difficult
and
after a semester of teaching
you have no idea how much i i'm i'm
looking forward to the break so it's not
like teaching is
you know i
when i teach i want out
do you find that to be true even if it's
an undergraduate course the reason i ask
this is that i imagine as a professor
the undergraduate material you could
teach with your pinky you don't have to
think much about it because you first of
all you've mastered it second you've
taught it for years and years i do not
teach the same class
for years
like
i think the maximum i've ever repeated
the class
uh was like three years
so it's not
but
but even then
uh you always have to prepare
uh
you always blunder i always blunder
maybe perfect people don't
but you know i always blunder uh
here and there and then i have to figure
out ways out
i always
find new things to do new ways to do
things i always um
even when i repeat but essentially but
most of the time i don't repeat
and the material is sometimes hard you
know so um
and even when it's not hard
so you know
on day one of the class
you teach of a linear algebra class you
teach the axioms of a vector space
i obviously know these axions
right i i obviously um
when i see a vector space
i know it
when i when when you give me a vector
space i know what to do with it
but that's not the same thing
as getting up in front of a class and
listing the axioms
and
making sure that you haven't forgotten
one small axiom somewhere
or that you phrase them perfectly so
that even people who have never seen
these things before will understand
um
so i mean even day one of a very basic
class uh requires preparation
we're gonna talk about mathematical
techniques
in fact i believe when we emailed you
said you don't like the emphasis on
theorems and proofs you like
well we can talk about that later
as for
teaching techniques i'm curious what
have you gleaned what have you found to
be productive and perhaps even some
behaviors you find to be unproductive
that you see other people other teachers
making the mistake of doing
i mean there is so much
uh
you know starting from
com
you know completely silly things like
make sure that you're heard
right if the classroom is large and you
speak without a microphone
uh people in the back are not going to
hear you and then
they're not going to follow
uh make sure that you can be seen
so if you write with a tiny you know if
you write tiny letters with a faded
chalk
uh
people can't read what you write uh
the class is a failure no matter what
you say
and then there are uh higher level
things and
basically everything should be motivated
so you know i mentioned the first class
of a linear the first class uh in a
linear algebra course
okay so you can give by uh you can give
by this class
by saying uh you can start this class by
saying let f be
a field
essent
v
is
called
a vector space if
and then you can write property you know
operations and properties and you know
you write item number one to item number
15
where 15 is i don't know some axioms
like alpha times beta times a vector
you know whatever so one of the axioms
of a vector field
okay of a vector sorry a vector space
uh
and then the question arises why
and who cares
right right okay so if you start your
class this way
people aren't going to like it so before
this
there has to be a a little section
i don't know here
where you explain
um
well for such and such reasons we care
about vector spaces so there has to be
motivation first
okay
and uh
and that's true
not only in the first class of the first
um
uh
of a linear algebra of course it's true
in every class whenever you say
something there has to be a reason
and the people who
um
who are listening to you uh
should know that you've thought about it
should know that you
that you're telling them these things
for a reason
okay
and
uh that's often omitted
it's often
too easy to just follow the definitions
in the theorems and never say what
they're good for
and um
and not only you should say these things
you should say them up from upfront
likewise when you write a proof uh
it's often easy to
well to
to so i mean often there is a picture
behind that proof
the proof is telling some story and you
and you want the picture of that story
in the minds of the students
but but but but it's often too easy to
reduce it to a
list of formulas
or a list of statements so a higher
level thing is to make sure that
everything is motivated
what else what's another higher level
aspect of teaching
that you find is a common mistake among
the teachers that you see
um
i think maybe this is the biggest
not showing the motivation clearly
enough
and by the way
uh
that's part of the reason why research
is a necessary part of teaching
because
uh
you have to know the motivation
you know you can say
vector spaces are a great thing
unless you've actually worked with them
unless you've actually seen them used
so maybe vector spaces are good and are
easy enough so that you can um
uh
um
you know by third year you understand
why you why you learned about them in
first year
but if you want to be able to say
something intelligent about homology you
have to have used it
the only way to use it is in research
so uh
uh
so that's what i meant by you have to be
in shape being in shape also means
remember what
what can be done with these things
do you find that you're more creative as
you get older
or that your creativity peaked at a
certain age
i you
you know i i wish i could answer the
truth is that
i don't really remember
you know i i mean
it's very hard to remember myself at any
other age
so i mean certainly
um
i have matured
so the little i can remember from 20 or
30 years ago um
is
is that i have matured okay
uh
i'm more systematic perhaps
than i was
am i smarter am i more creative am i
stupider am i less creative i'm not sure
what do you mean when you say you're
more systematic now can you give an
example of how you would look at a
certain problem now or solve it versus
20 years prior
and also a sub question do you see being
systematic as a good thing or do you see
there being innovation in being
disorganized or creativity embedded
there
no systematic is generally better
so i used to be
much
more into the low hanging fruits
so
and i was lucky that i found some
but
[Music]
but basically i'd
i'd uh
like wait for opportunities and and then
use them
okay
uh and
uh
now it's much more i have a long-term
goal
uh
you know i want uh
a theory of something
you know your your your uh
podcast is a theory of everything right
i just want a theory of something
so i want a theory of something because
i i feel for various reasons that it
ought to be there
and then i
um
[Music]
worked very hard
on
well very hard to my standards i already
admitted being a bomb so um
you know i i worked at least for a long
time
uh trying to find that theory
you know even assist even even at a very
at a much lower level
uh
so
i think when i was first year student
uh
you know so you know math theorems and
proofs were
pressed into my brain was essentially an
external process right so i went to
classes and people pushed theorems into
my brain
and
um
some of
them seemed like complete formalities
like
a sequence of deductions
uh that i could have that i could
memorize and i could
verify
but were essentially created by aliens
you know i i had no idea how they came
to be
right in some theorems
uh
immediately
uh
became a picture i immediately
understood
uh
uh
that
that the proof describes a certain
geometric reality
okay describe
i i i i could see the intuition behind
the proof
it's not always geometric though it's
just you see the internet necessarily
geometric i mean but i could see somehow
the motivation the the the i i could
imagine how the proof was discovered
i think i i i would get the feeling that
i understood the proof and there and and
that was essentially a dichotomy some
pictures some proofs
or some concept were of that type
made by aliens
and pushed into my brain by professors
and other
um uh concepts theorems proofs whatever
were clearly intuitive and made sense
and and i understood them
uh and that was it that was the world
there was this and there were those
and then sometime later in second year i
actually did my ba very very very
quickly so uh basically
i did it in essentially two years
so when i say second year you should
compare it maybe with year three and
four of um most students
so somewhere later in late in my studies
i realized
that if i think harder
about the theorems that
uh or the concepts that appear to be
alien
then sooner or later
i see the picture behind them sooner or
later i realize
uh
that
i i'm able to move them to the other
class
the class of things that are motivated
and and and um
and understand it and understood
and
and and then i became systematic about
it
so
every time i learn something new
i may learn it from a book that
describes it as a formula
okay and then i'll struggle to see the
intuition behind the formula
and so even at that level it's it's
something that took learning
it it wasn't um
again when i got to the university
you know when i when i was in first year
i took classes and i got good gr good
grades in in in all of them
um
and nevertheless
uh
there was a point where
where things became better where where i
realize i can actually
understand everything
and not just repeat everything
and that came later
what does that process of finding the
intuition behind let's say a formula
that before you
previously simply had to memorize as
handed down from the gods or the aliens
what does that process look like the
process of finding the intuition does it
look like
i'm sure it's a variety of these but
does it majorly look like you copy it
down with the pen and paper precisely
and then you draw arrows and you say
okay so what's an example of this what's
a counter example of this or is it you
go on a bike ride and you keep thinking
about it what does that process look
like perhaps it would be edifying if you
took a specific example but if you can't
then just give the broad strokes
ah
you know what it what does it look like
from the outside from the outside it
looks like i'm sitting on my chair and
staring into the into infinity
right or
sitting on my balcony and looking at the
view
what does it look like inside
it's very hard to answer without
without going through specific examples
and the specific examples are
far too complex or i i don't know if
they are far too complex but they fit in
a math class
and the other thing is um
you will never see these examples in my
classes because when i teach something i
try to motivate it
okay
so you will not see the alternative
okay you will see the motivated way of
explaining uh uh the
implicit function theorem or the uh
change of variables formula for multi
integrals right you'll see the motivated
form you will not see it
i will not be showing you the
unmotivated
formulas for you much of the time when
it's difficult for you to understand a
proof or a theorem or concept is it
most of the time because it was
unmotivated
well the intuition is not explained
often
so in textbooks
uh
often the intuition is not explained
now
some intuition is just getting used to
the concepts
so sometimes intuition is not is not
um
it's just playing around until you're
used to it
you know
uh
you've just landed in a foreign city
you've just landed in athens
uh
your hotel
is two kilometers from the acropolis
uh you got there at night you wake up in
the morning you want to go to the
acropolis
you
punch acropolis into google maps
and google maps tells you
you know go left go right go straight go
left go right and here's the cro
acropolis okay you follow the
instructions
you didn't learn atoms
you've learned the way to the acropolis
uh to learn athens
uh
in the afternoon after the acropolis you
have to wander around
uh and then you have to continue
wandering around for the next two weeks
and then maybe you're starting to have a
grasp of what athens is
so there is similar
there is something similar in in
mathematics
okay or in science or in fact in every
field of learning okay i mean but in
mathematics you know um
uh you don't
uh
learn
i mean if you learn a proof of something
if you've if you learn the proof of the
most interesting result result in a
certain field
you haven't learned the field
okay you've just learned and especially
if you if you follow the directions by
somebody else
okay
the learning happens if you wander
around later
and in a way you have to do it on your
own
right this this wandering around so
wandering around in mathematics means
you experiment you change the conditions
you
you ask yourself what if you remove what
if you add conditions what
what happens if you look at analogous
situations
but these things um
well so i mean
like part of tourism you do with a tour
guide and part of an and a part you have
to do on your own on your own
and um
uh so so so so some part of uh
being systematic if you wish is doing
this on my own thing in a systematic way
okay this realization that i can just
jump into a topic by
following somebody's guidance
i i
i must sit down and think and ask myself
many many many many more questions and
go on side tracks and until until it's
until eventually i'm comfortable
now in this example
let me let me see if i'm understanding
it correctly let's say athens athens the
city and then you have the acropolis
which is a landmark so that's almost
like a landmark theorem and then the
directions are the proof and the steps
to get there
would you say and you're saying the
learning comes from the wandering would
you say that when you first land in
athens you should wander or should you
learn the major landmarks and the
directions to get there perhaps
forgetting the directions you just get
yourself there so that you see what the
landmarks are like later you wonder the
analogy would be you learn the major
theorems and then later you try and get
the intuition by playing around with
them or do you play from the get-go i
mean there has to be a bit of both
uh basically you know if you land in
athens and start wondering randomly you
end up you may end up wandering randomly
in a completely uninteresting direction
plus there is a fear factor
and you know you may feared about
neighborhoods
interesting but but but but there
actually is an analog an analogy in
mathematics or
it
no it's i mean you fear doing certain
things and the guidance
can help you overcome the fear but maybe
fear is not the right way i mean think
that you have to explore atoms when when
it's dark
okay so you simply don't know which way
to go you just land
you know i tell you think about vector
spaces you have no idea what good
questions to ask are what are the good
questions to ask
and
um
[Music]
so you need guidance
or else you will be stuck in one
neighborhood and never realize that
there is more than that
but you know after the guidance took you
from here to there
you have to
go back and explore and explore more and
explore more and until you until it's a
solid and not just a single path
so you have to do your own finding path
integral over the space of mathematical
ideas there is a bit of that yes
what's your greatest strength as a
mathematician or some of your strengths
who says i have strengthens
what's your greatest weakness
i'm a lazy bum
are you being modest when you say that
because i imagine someone who has an
accelerated degree two-year degree that
should ordinarily take four years it's
not as if you spend the majority of your
time playing video games and
and being on industrious oh you'll be
surprised
uh
i mean of course i didn't play video
games and that was back in the 80s
you know video video games came later
uh
but
i definitely killed a lot of time
so who are you comparing yourself to
when you say that you're slothful
gee i compare i compare myself to who i
want to be
anyway
what are my strengths
i think i'm decently good at explaining
things to others
um
often that involves thinking about them
i mean
explaining is not just
uh
reproducing what you've heard somewhere
else i mean it's it's first of all
being creative about these things
um
but you know
uh
ask the students
ask the people who listen to me in
lectures
when i give research
lectures um
it's very hard to
uh
you know
there's a famous uh story about einstein
that
somebody complained to einstein about
his problems with math
and their reference was to high school
math like i never got high school math
and
einstein said let me assure you that my
math problems are way bigger
uh
so
uh
sort of meaning what what did he mean by
that
you know i
einstein spent
all his life struggling with mathematics
not just high school time
okay so in a similar way uh gee i'm
sorry i mean now it might sound like i
need some analogy which i do i'm not
making
i understand trust me uh but but still
um
you know i like to implement
i like to compute things
implement them on the computer
which means that i spend a lot of time
programming the concepts i work on
turning them into running programs
you could say it's my strength but when
i look at it
all i see is that i'm struggling and
struggling and struggling and failing
and here and then here and there there
is a minor success
which gets superseded a little bit later
by somebody else
so
um
yeah maybe one of my strengths is the
ability to implement things
to turn to to actually
you know turn mathematical concepts into
running programs
uh
but it's also one of the things that
that keeps me depressed uh was so much
of my time
some people who are watching this they
may be discouraged because they were
they weren't particularly great at high
school mathematics or some people may
have struggled during their undergrad
what advice do you have for those people
if they want to continue to learn
mathematics or physics at a
graduate perhaps even larger than
graduate phd level
do they just continue
plugging away and not feel discouraged
because they feel like in imbecile on a
daily basis
what advice do you have for them
there is chug along
and there is realize when it's not
working
and i hate to tell you that i don't know
i mean i can't give you a
a
a clear recipe to decide which one it is
um
different people are different
some people struggle and struggle and
struggle until
they succeed sometimes some people don't
uh or they struggle and struggle and
struggle and don't succeed
you get
feedback
i mean
some people depend on daily feedback
some people can leave with a feedback
with a bit of feedback once a year
i i'm not sure i have a
a clear answer
what did you learn from ed whitton with
respect to mathematical techniques or
meta mathematical so how you should
think about
math
or physics
well i learned specific mathematics from
him
right so you know i learned like many
other people i learned this formula
from him
right and how to read it and how to use
use it interpret it work with it right
do things with it
but i learned many other specific things
with him
from him
um
i learned from him he's actually um i
mean like
people think of him as a great
researcher
but he's also a great expositor
so
when you come to his lectures
he is
uh
able to make
even very complicated things appear
simple
uh
the problem is that often you will not
see that because he's turning the hyper
complicated into merely complicated
uh so so so so so you don't
automatically realize
uh what a great uh exposition
uh work he had done
and i i
think i learned well i don't know if i
learned that from him
but i strive to learn that from him
um
and then in other ways i
there are senses in which i didn't learn
anything from him
namely uh he is
so much more talented
there's just no way of no other way of
saying it the guy is smart
the guy is extremely productive
uh if you try to imitate his
brilliance
you'll fail
at least i failed
uh if you try to imitate his
productivity you'll just be disappointed
so
um
in some ways i haven't learned there are
certain things i haven't learned from
him and i just simply couldn't
do you mind describing your relationship
with eric weinstein when i was speaking
to eric he said that you acted as a de
facto supervisor to him
because raul bot wasn't particularly
although it was officially his
supervisor he didn't act as the
supervisor for whatever reason it was a
strange relationship i don't understand
it
i'm curious what do you think he means
when he says that you acted as the
supervisor you gave him advice or i
don't think it's correct it's more like
a coach or you know i mean
so eric
eric was very unbalanced
and he still is unbalanced and i don't
mean emotionally unbalanced i mean
uh he has
great talents
in certain directions
and
fear
of others
and there are certain
things that one has to do certain type
of computation a certain type of writing
basically he has fear of turning his um
his
theories too concrete
uh so um
[Music]
uh
and and that's
part of the reason why he had difficulty
uh
with raul balt and with um
basically with the normal system in
harvard
and
my role was to help him pick something
concrete out of his
big theories
and
and
and push it enough so that it became a
thesis
uh
yeah i also helped him with some
computations you know i you know
at the end of the day there are some
like so so he's come he's
you know big theories
lead to something very concrete and
specific which was a tiny part of the
big theories but we extracted that tiny
part and made it uh more concrete and at
the end it became a question you know
some big matrix 500 by 500 or whatever
it was
is it positive definite or not
and i helped him uh i helped him
decide that
and that was decided by compute by a
computer like you ended up programming
it that one that one was decided by
computer
so we just
uh but
but
but that's the kind of thing he would
have never done on on his own
because
he has this
fear of
uh
in a way it's a fear of testing your
theories
because they might fail but in another
way it's just inability he never
learned how to do it he never got good
at um
turning the very abstract into concrete
um
so yes so that was my role
have you read his recent geometric unity
papers or heard about geometric unity at
all i've heard a tiny bit about it i
have not read it i'm not in the position
to comment
you talked about it's difficult to make
a concrete or take something concrete
from a theory at least in his case
do you mind giving an example of his
strengths or some or an example of a
brilliance of his that you saw
he
intimately knows
the small groups and their
representations
uh
how they
interact with each other
uh so
uh
the small groups like the classical
groups or what do you mean when you say
the smoke
okay what i mean by the small is um
so you know
uh
there are several families of so-called
symmetry groups
okay so there are uh
uh s-u-n
and s-uh
and s-o-n
and s-p-n
and then there are a few sporadic ones
there is uh
uh g2 and f4
and e6 and e7
and e8 and it doesn't go beyond eight
uh and all of these so these are
abstract things these are groups
they they have so-called representation
theory
so
uh
each one of them can be represented can
be written as a group of matrices can be
realized within the world of matrices
but in many ways
so eric
uh
intimately knows
um
these groups
and their representations and how they
sit inside each other
for small values of n
and well for all of those sporadic ones
which are all small
and their symmetries and their so-called
outer symmetries i mean he knows all
about
uh
these things
now
this is relevant to physics
because
uh you know electro weak theory is
somehow about su 2
and
the grand unified theory so a strong and
electroweak is somehow about su 3
or
so
uh no no no no no i have it wrong
sorry electromagnetism is
well electromagnetism
is you one and then
you know i
i i
i i actually have not thought about
these things for many many years
so i could be saying things wrong
but yeah but his strength is that he
knows these things really really really
well
uh
or one of his strengths is that he knows
these things really really really well
earlier when we were talking about
particle physics well not theory you
mentioned that for every knot there's a
corresponding physics story of particles
dancing and so on is the opposite true
so does the arrow go in the other
direction as well
for every particle interaction is there
a corresponding knot
for every particle interaction of a
specific type
in three-dimensional space
yes
but uh but you have to
be very specific you have to be you have
to specialize a great deal
physics mostly happens in
four-dimensional space
if this can be easily explained why is
it not simple to just extend the three
dimensions to four dimensions
and
and come up with answers much like in
vector in we're talking about vector
spaces it's trivial to go from r3 to r4
the same theorems apply okay so so the
answer is
um
or there's
first of all certain things do extend
so
um
you know if not
theory is
to some extent about dance the dancing
of points in two-dimensional space
so
you know he he
here is a
a very rough uh
uh
uh kind of correspondence okay
so
uh not theory
or
ordinary notes
is roughly about
one
dimensional
things
or curves or whatever
in
three-dimensional space
and as i mentioned before
it can be
um
interpreted
as
points dancing
in two-dimensional place space
so points are zero dimensional
so
uh you can
uh
so you can interpret no theory as zero
dimensional things
right a single point is a zero
dimensional thing
so it's zero dimensional things
dancing
in
a
two-dimensional
space now
you can lift this
one dimension up
so you can say
uh let's uh
uh instead of
zero dimensional things dancing in r2
you can think of one-dimensional
things
dancing
in
uh
r
four
and one dimensional things dancing in r4
somehow correspond by the same
correspondence looking at the
sections
they somehow corresponds
to
two-dimensional notes so two-dimensional
things are noted
in
r4
now you can ask
now what exactly are what is that
supposed to be r3 dancing sorry not r4 i
i wanted to add one this is in r2 adding
one you get r3
sorry so one dimensional thing dancing
in r3
now you can ask yourself what are one
dimensional things dancing in r3 and
fortunately i'm ready for that
so here are here is a one dimensional
thing
and here's another one
and
uh right this is a loop it's a
one-dimensional thing that's another one
it's a loop it's a one-dimensional thing
and they can dance around they can fly
in r3 and they can fly in interesting
ways that don't exist one dimension less
namely they can fly through each other
okay
so
yes there is a theory of one-dimensional
things dancing in r3
and it corresponds to a theory of
two-dimensional spaces noted inside
four-dimensional space
so to some extent
the answer to your question is yes there
is higher there are higher dimensional
analogs of not theory
it turns out
that
uh
some features are different
it turns out that in some ways uh
and they're actually qualitatively
sort of the theory of not in one them so
so you know unlike um vector spaces
so vector spaces you kind of once you
learn
r3
r4 you've learned r to the 50.
okay
but but but here there are qualitative
differences
so
uh
so
some things from the study here
translate to things here and vice versa
but not everything
so
myself i've spent most of my time
actually on these two
okay
but then there is higher there is even
higher stuff
um
by the way so you know
um
linear algebra
uh
when you take
a first class in linear algebra and
maybe also a second class in linear
algebra you get this impression
that
uh everything is the same in all
dimensions
yep
but that's not true
even in linear algebra even in linear
algebra
so
well not quite linear algebra but in
algebra
okay so you know there is something
called uh the real numbers
then you can
add i
add i
and you get the complex numbers
and then
uh you can say
let's add uh j and k as well
and you get
uh the so-called uh quaternions
but the quaternions are different than
the complex numbers in that this is a
commutative
ring
and this is a non-commutative ring
and then you can add g i forgot what's
the standard name for what you add so i
don't know add
in
in stand for stands for nameless because
i forgot the name and and you get
octaniums and the octaniums are no
longer even associative
so it's still sort of a ring
namely it has a multiplication but it's
not even associative and then the
process ends there is just nothing
beyond that you can't continue
uh so
uh
so even in linear algebra so that's not
quite well
i don't know even in basic algebra not
all dimensions are the same 1 is not the
same as 2 is not the same as 4 is not
the same as 8 and not the same as 16
where things no longer exist
so
so it's just not true
that
[Music]
things are independent of the dimension
it's only they're only independent of
the dimension in the first two years of
uh
of of undergrad
now in this example we're going to
different spaces by adding one
or by adding whatever extra
variables there are there in the
previous example we're extending r 4 to
r 5 or
r n to n plus m
so we're in the same space in a sense
except adding an extra dimension so
what's an example that holds for r3
or actually sorry let's make this even
simpler what's an example that holds for
r2 but doesn't hold for r3
or you can say r3 to r4 like what's an
example of a quantity that drastically
changes as soon as you go to r4
and becomes
extremely complicated but in r3 it's
trivial
the motion of points
is fundamentally different
in
two dimensions versus in three
dimensions
so let me explain
so
uh
right suppose you have two points a and
b
in two dimensions
and you want them to trade places by
moving
okay there are two basic ways they can
do it they can trade place
by
uh b going above a
or
they can trade places
uh in some sort sort of the opposite way
by a going above b so a will go to here
and b will go sorry a will go
a
will go take the upper root
and b take the the lower root
these are
these two ways are somehow fundament
they're somehow fundamentally distinct
uh and you know to use technical
language you cannot homotope this way to
that way
they're not homotopic you cannot
continuously deform
this way of moving to that way of moving
but in r3 that's not
true anymore so in r3
points can trade places
in only one way
so
uh let me uh find two points for you
so
uh i suppose
uh
well they're not points but they're
close to points so here is uh red and
blue
so in r3 they can trade places going
this way
or they can trade places going that way
but there are many other ways they can
trade places they can trade places by
going that way or
that way
and
um
in a sense all of these
trading places ways
are equivalent to each other
because
if you trade places
wait if the two points trade places
they span a circle
right so
basically let me use this right so you
know they
spun a circle by
uh i wish i had a third hand maybe i
removed my sure sure sure okay they go
like that okay that spawns a circle and
the other way of spawning a circle is by
going the other way
around the same d around the same sorry
circle
but now i can flip that circle over
and that homotops that deforms
one way of trading places to the other
way of trading places so in r3
so in r2 there are two
distinct
sorry this
can spell there are two
uh
distinct
ways
of
uh
trading
uh places
and in fact two are easy they're
actually a little bit more but anyway in
r3
so if you're talking about
three-dimensional space
and you have
two points in the three-dimensional
space there is
only
one
way
or one or all way or let no let me say
different let me say differently
uh all ways of trading places all
ways
of
trading
uh places
are
equivalent and again the basic the basic
point is that a way of trading places is
a circle right right one point goes
along one arc and the other point goes
about a guy over the other arc and you
can
switch from one place of trading place
one way of trading places to the other
by flipping the circle you can't do it
if you're only in the plane
um
since trading places is actually
fundamental it makes uh
but by the way it's also fundamental in
physics
so you know you you you know you you
might have heard of uh bosons and
fermions and how they behave
with respect to trading places and then
there are any ons that behave yet
differently uh with respect to trading
places so basically trading places or
how things behave under trading places
is a fundamental
thing
and it's different it's it's different
in two dimensions than in three
right likewise there are things that are
different between three dimensions and
four
and and so it's actually this kind of
myth or not myth but this um
the thing that you learn in first and
second year that uh rn is the same rn no
matter what n is is not actually true
have you heard of the hard problem of
consciousness
i have not heard it in this language
namely no no has nothing to do with
what was written on the board or maybe
it does but not as far as i see this is
sort of a clear philosophical problem
right but uh with the added prefix the
high and it's clearly hard
but but but as a phrase the hard problem
of consciousness i don't know what
you're talking about
there's only one consciousness that i
need to explain and it's my own
right from my perspective
you're not conscious
right you just react to
to to things that i do you know if i
you know if i tell you
uh you're stupid you get angry at me if
i give you a compliment you get happy
but these are all
i don't see consciousness here
okay i so there's only one consciousness
that i have to explain
and only one person that i have to
explain it to and it's myself
um
but anyway uh
having said that
um
yeah i'll keep the rest private
what keeps you up at night
different things on different days
whether she loves me or not
uh
whether i can
complete the computer program or i'm
writing or not or why is it not written
my classes for tomorrow the theorem i
don't know how to
have no clue how to prove the state of
the world
covered i don't know different things at
different times
is there a through line so let's say one
that you've been thinking about for 15
years or more
you know i'm politically aware
and always been have always been so uh
uh
you know how to make the world a better
place
uh but but of course that's a subjective
thing what what is better
to me may or may not be the same as what
is better to you
so in a way when i'm saying
uh how to make a better pla the world a
better place it's more like how to make
the world more like
i would how i would like it to be
yeah so i think about it a lot and
mostly my conclusion is that there's
nothing i can do or there is much i can
do
my powers are limited
what direction would you like math
research to head
i think i mentioned
that i like computation
um
and i actually uh
so i mean it's not the only thing of
value
in mathematics
right there are things in mathematics
with great philosophical value
regardless of whether they are
computable or not
but
but those parts of mathematics that can
be computed
uh are often not
and often
people
uh
just don't care about computations they
pretend
that
well
they think of computation as something
as a technical thing to to to live for
their graduate students
and i see it as a much more integral
part of the work
so
if i were to change i would um
i i i would make computation a bigger
part
computation in the sense of
implementation on the computer not in
the sense of writing by hand
i would make it a much bigger part and i
would um
and that happens at many levels so when
you teach a class in linear algebra
you teach about uh
how to compute the determinant
well
uh
along with it there should be a computer
program to compute compute the
determinant
and should and there should be a
realization that there are maybe two
formulas for the determinant and one of
them is way better than the other
uh
if you try to implement it
uh so
um
i would
emphasize computation much more
um
yeah maybe that would be the main change
do you have a philosophy of math so for
example there's platonism and formalism
if anything i would be an ultra
finalitist
so
uh
it's much more graded than that
so you know there is a hierarchy
of
um
of
complexities of things
or sizes
of things in mathematics
so
you know people in set theory and logic
and you know talk about
large cardinal axioms
and
then there are
parts of mathematics that have to do
with uncountable or
bigger than uncountable
and then there are infinite parts
and then there are just infinite without
being uncountable right and just
countable say and then there are parts
of mathematics that are um
finite but huge
uh so you know ramsey theory
uh
you have uh
you know you prove that if a graph is
large enough then it has properties
certain properties
but large enough means really really
really really really really really
really huge bigger than the number of
atoms in the universe
uh and then there are
uh
you know parts of mathematics
uh
that happens where uh the numbers
are uh between 10 to the 6
and 10 to the 12 i don't know what a
computer can do in a fraction of a
second to what a computer can do in an
hour
okay and you know maybe you can go a
little bit beyond to 10 to the 16 i
don't know 10 to the 15. i don't know
okay
so there is this whole grading
and to me
the bigger things are
the less important they are
uh
and
because they're farther away from our
everyday experience
so they may have philosophical value and
some of them do
so i don't want to
completely
say
anything about large cardinals is not
interesting
or anything about infinity
is not interesting
but the bar is higher
for something that genuinely use uses
infinity
to be interesting
the bar is higher
than if the thing is
uh
in this in the range of sizes
that we can actually hold in our hands
so that's what i mean by an ultra
finitist i mean
sort of the
or or so this is a form so an ultra
finalities would say the only numbers
that exist are the numbers i could count
to
and maybe by uh
extension that my computer could count
to so maybe my computer can count up to
this number but 10 to the 100 does not
exist in some sense because my computer
will never be able to count there
okay we'll never be able to get there
so
i'm not an extreme i would say sometimes
there is value to this one too
and sometimes there is even value to
infinity and sometimes there is even
value to the bigger form of infinity but
the bar has to be higher
uh the the the the philosophical value
bar has to be higher
the bigger the the size is
these things are always interesting
these things are interesting only on
special circumstances
now i'm not sure do you classify
yourself as a pure mathematician
definitely
okay so for a pure mathematician who
seemingly doesn't care about reality
it's supposed to be discontinued again
the valuable math is the math that i can
or the more valuable math
is the math that i can turn into a
computer program
it's still pure math in the sense that
i'm not looking for an immediate or a
specific application
uh but
both from the application perspective
and from the pedagogical perspective
i still prefer
the map that the math that can be
implemented because the math that can be
implemented even if i'm not looking for
an immediate application
is there is the math that has a higher
chance
of being applied
because in the application you'll end up
computing
and also
from the teaching perspective from the
pedagogical perspective
there is more value
to the education you give
if it comes with implementation because
you want your students to be able to
implement the things that they learn
yes sorry what were you asking oh i was
saying you ultimately care about the
practical aspect of math even though
you're operating in pure mathematics
ultimately yes though possibly very
indirectly
so maybe the way the math i'm doing
or maybe the
maybe the way i care is in that the pure
math i'm doing
uh enables me to teach graduate students
who will then become college instructors
and their students will be able to uh
uh
actually
implement the mathematics they're
learning
so i mean it it doesn't have to be
immediate and direct
but yes i do care about
how at the end it gets applied
or how i get the end it it becomes
applicable
great now we just have some audience
questions i asked people beforehand
what are some questions you have for
professor jor barnetten so the
scientific mystical philosopher that's
the username he wants to know he or she
wants to know why the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics
sorry
why is mathematics unreasonably
effective
gee i don't know
ask a god
uh
she may or may not be able to give you
an answer
um
yeah it's weird we live in a predictable
universe
uh
right when we throw something up in the
air it always uh
shows this you know goes through the
same trajectory
uh
nearly i don't know i mean
that's a miracle
roman gekwad wants to know have you ever
had your iq scored
and if not what do you believe it is
no clue
uh and also
you know iq scores are very limited in
many ways are very uh
you know are
you know there is a fun story
uh
uh that i
i've never verified it but i heard it
okay
that
um
when the people who introduced iq tests
first introduced them they run them on
test subjects
and
the women the females
got higher scores than the men
that was back in the 50s or i don't know
exactly when but there was a long time
ago they figured hey that's impossible
uh and then they tweaked the tests again
a bit they changed the nature of the
questions they asked them differently
until they finally were able
to uh to make um uh men uh equal or
maybe better i don't know than women
and again this is true
to a certain system of education in a
certain time
right
men and women did not receive the same
education
uh
it would have been easy to do to
distinguish
because
they came as as their backgrounds were
different
uh so you could arrange
uh
such things
okay
uh
uh
that's about the value of iq
of iq scores
okay they were
i mean
to some extent they measured something
to some extent they were cooked to
measure whatever people wanted them to
measure
not much to learn from these
measurements
tori cole has
a question what do you think of biology
slash psychology slash philosophy
i think they're fun i think they're
foundational to understanding myself and
therefore my experience of the universe
do you think you would gain much of an
understanding
of an exploration from those fields to
mathematics
again biology
biology psychology and philosophy
i mean
they're all interesting fields i am not
sure
what more to say you know
do you think there are insights there
that if you were to read a biology book
a psychology book perhaps a philosophy
book
do you think there are insights to be
gleaned from there that you can then
apply to mathematics
there are connections here and there
um
much of mathematics is independent of
that
uh
so
[Music]
obviously
biology motivates parts of mathematics
so parts of mathematics
uh
you know are about modeling biological
systems
when we
compute the fibonacci numbers we give
examples of uh the reproduction rules of
rabbits
okay
and and then there is much more like
that and and then um
likewise for psychology
uh
but
and likewise and and and of course
philosophy so you know there are
bits of mathematics of great
philosophical values so
you know gideon's theorem says
uh
that there are all there will always be
things we do not we will not know
okay or said diff or or differently i
know there is no algorithm to decide
uh
to find the proofs of theorems
uh these things have philosophical value
okay
uh
for most mathematicians it's not
a
day-to-day working relationship
my own mathematics
benefits very little
if any
from the
from contact with biology
uh
philosophy and psychology
okay phil thomas wants to know what led
him what led you professor to the field
of mathematics and is your field
something you think virtually anyone can
learn
what led me there
you know
it's a question about my life story
right so what led me there is essentia
is is
um
a sequence of uh coincidences and
misunderstandings i don't know
a number of things but
so
um
to some extent to some extent i was good
at that
and that
pushed me to do more of it
and that's a very common answer for very
many things right people tend to do what
they're good at
misunderstandings you said
misunderstandings as well yes to some
extent uh
i misunderstood math
so
you know there was a time that i really
liked uh computers and electronics
i uh at some point
realized that there is a lot of kind of
hard work in it
so
uh
writing a computer program is very hard
you have to write hundreds of lines of
code and then
debug them and they whatever and
similarly for electronics right you have
to place those transistors on the board
and solder them together and
solder them together and
and you always get it wrong and you know
there is a lot of hard work where
mathematics is so much easier all you
have to do is to prove theorems
that was a complete misunderstanding i
mean i thought it was like much purer
uh i didn't
at the time i didn't realize how much
hard work is involved
so in some sense i got there i go to
mathematics by misunderstanding by being
lazy and not realizing that
i'm i'm
getting trapped into into a place where
laziness is is not
it is is not always enough
and also at the end i ended up liking
those parts that i first thought i was
going away from namely computation
so i ended up i mean computation to me
was like a childhood thing and a later
acquired taste
there was a period in between when in
between when i thought i was pure i
would never compute anything
um
right what else did i answer or did i
mean there was a second part to the
question do you believe that your field
either the field of mathematics or your
subfield the one that you're working in
currently do you feel that your field is
something that virtually anyone can
learn
no
uh
so
uh
some
uh some amount of mathematics
everybody can learn
and everybody should learn
and maybe it's more
than what is taught in uh
in our current educational system
education system okay
uh
but
um
you know i
i will never catch up with ed wheaton
okay
the
the amount of stuff that he knows the
depth of the stuff the the depth by
which he knows things
i'll never get there
it's not i'm not talented enough to get
there
it might be that in my 30 years in the
subject i've learned things that uh
most people
also wouldn't be able to catch up with
so
you know
there is the mushizuki proof of the abc
conjecture
disputed
okay moshizuki claims it's a proof other
people think it isn't
i will never be in the position to
understand that
i mean
possibly if i started early enough i'm
not even sure
i happen to know moshizuki i remember
him when he was young we we were friends
when like we went we're went to graduate
school together
so i uh
so i remember him when he was young
he was smarter and faster than me
it's conceivable that after 20 years
he's gone so far
that i will never be able to catch up
it's equally possible that
there are people who would never be able
to catch up with me
um
[Music]
they said
some amount of mathematics
is useful to everybody
you know
we're we're now in the in the midst of a
pandemic
understanding what's the exponential
function
is something that
is basic knowledge is something that
every human should
should have
because it actually dictates if it tells
us something
about how to behave
uh at this time
uh
likewise making various probabilistic
estimates
you know
if the chance of such and such type of
side effects is is one in a million what
does it mean
what does one in a million means in
practical term for me terms for me
should i fear it
or is it so remote that i have that i
can ignore it
so basic numeracy is is is is an
absolute necessary ingredient and for
everyone
and can be reached by everyone
when you mentioned that you'll never be
able to catch up to whitten and may
perhaps some people won't be able to
catch up to you and so on
what is that a function of biology you
mentioned the word talent so is it is
that just innate is
is what's innate called intelligence is
that associated with iq like what are
you referring to when you say you won't
be able to catch up
it's a number of things
you can call it talent
you can call it iq if you wish but of
course there is no numerical measurement
and it's a much much more complicated
thing so um
you know so much of
how far you can get in mathematics
depends on how much you concentrate on
mathematics
so you know uh
maybe when you're
if at a certain part of your life you're
able to completely isolate yourself and
think on nothing but mathematics
you'll end up knowing more mathematics
than if you are also a human a human
along
alongside
okay uh
so
uh
so so talent is also
circumstance and
uh
and luck
and
in some sense being narrow-minded
so now being narrow-minded helps in
certain ways
uh
speaking of eric weinstein you mentioned
him
okay so
so
so he was very unbalanced he had great
talent for certain kind of things and
great fear of others
and
maybe he would have been a much more
famous mathematician physicist now
if if it wasn't for these
coincidences
so um
i don't know
i mean
you could call it
innate you could call it
uh learn you can call it many things but
it's a very complicated combination of
things
tyler goldstein has a question
do you think we need to make new
research institutions that aren't linked
to academia
and i imagine what he's referring to
is something that weinstein has brought
up in wolfram as well
they're not huge fans of the peer review
process or at least they're not huge
fans of only
thinking that work
is worth it if it's gone through the
peer review process
and
while that's associated with academia
i'm curious if you have any thoughts as
to that
well there are things outside of
academia
it's not
arguably most research is done outside
of academia
i mean you know there are a lot of a lot
of research is done inside companies
inside
well a lot of research is done outside
of the peer review process
um
but overall i think the system is
reasonable
sorry overall you think the system is i
think the system is reasonable
so
uh you know you can um
say bad things as much as you want about
peer review
but it's better than the alternatives
it's better than having no review
um
you can say
uh
maybe mathematical should be more
hierarchical
okay there should be big bosses
who
determine which theorems we should be
proving
and then they should
have their
smaller bosses who would be responsible
to specific theorems and they would be
the big bosses of other people who would
be proving dilemmas
you could say something like that it
sounds like it sounds ridiculous it
would work just as ridiculously as it
sounds
current system is
you know
given
given the limitations of humans is is
reasonably good i believe there are some
arguments to say that
the what you just outlined is
somewhat like it happens given grant
agencies they have some field that they
fund and so then the research tends to
go toward there so you can view them as
the large boss and i believe lee smallin
makes some arguments saying that that's
why string theory is as large as as it
is even though it shouldn't be because
we haven't seen much success from it and
so on so do you see what you just
outlined as the ridiculous scenario do
you see that as having any bearing to
how it actually is
so
yes of course there is bias
generated by the granting agencies by
the powerful people
be them be them the writing granting
agencies or the editorial boards of
journals
so you know
if you publish if you have a result
uh that somebody on the editorial board
of an excellent journal uh
likes
you know that's close to the field of
somebody in the editorial board of an
excellent excellent journal then your
result is much more likely to get
published in this uh excellent journal
and then you're much more likely to get
tenure and then
more work will be produced in that field
and you'll advise students who will
produce even more more work on that
field
yes it all exists
but
it's not clear that you can think of a
better alternative
and also
there is still some amount of academic
freedom so the granting agency
decides once every five years
what my funding will be
in those five years some of my time i do
what is necessary to get my next grant
but some of the time i also do things
that i think are useful that i think are
useful
uh likewise
uh
you know some of my career
is is determined by which journal i
publish in but some is determined by
uh other factors
okay by the results that aren't
published by the lectures that i give in
conferences in china you know
it's much more multi-dimensional
than uh
than just having a boss and the boss is
the granting agency
even the fact that the editorial boards
are different than the review boards of
the granting agencies allows make some
variety
and again what is the alternative
so you know
one stupid alternative would be to say
to allow anyone to say
i am a mathematician
uh here is my proof that
pi is rational
or that you can
divide you know
here is my proof of the uh goldbach
conjecture
who's arguing with me i'm saying it's a
proof
my my word is as strong as yours
it's much better not to lose control
completely
you just use the word mathematician and
i'm curious what do you see as a
mathematician is it someone who's a
professor of math is this someone who
gets their masters or phd do you have to
frequently publish research in order for
you to call yourself a mathematician
like what gives
obviously it's a nebulous term but it's
not extremely amorphous it's defined
so what do you define it as
uh it's hard to say
you know
um
many definitions don't have sharp
boundaries in fact only in mathematics
uh there are sharp boundaries between
things like either
the series is convergent or it is not
convergent but only and there is a very
very specific
uh criteria to decide only in
mathematics there are
uh sharp boundaries and now you're
asking a meta-mathematical question
you're asking a question about
mathematics not a question in
mathematics so there aren't
sharp boundaries so basically all of the
above you know
if you teach mathematics if you think a
lot about mathematics if your way of
thought is abstraction
uh
proof um
you know then that's mathematics but
but but you can always
you can always find the borderline
things that will be hard to decide
here's a reason why i'm asking because
not everyone can call themselves a
doctor i know that some people they get
their md and then they're no longer
practicing researchers they no longer
are connected with the field but then
they'll give health advice resting on
the laurel that they have an md and
they'll say well this comes from a
doctor
and i'm sure the same occurs in
mathematics though
to a much lesser degree same with
physics someone may say well i'm a
physicist because i
i have a degree from a university but
that in physics but that doesn't
necessarily make you a physicist doesn't
mean your physics works should be taken
more seriously because you have that
degree
if you're so if you're looking for a
set of thumb rules
to decide uh
uh which experts are to be trusted and
which should not
be them experts in mathematics or
experts in medicine
well the answer is these questions are
complicated
so you know in medicine uh
you probably have to look for the bigger
name doctors the more you know the more
established doctors because
the system actually does
on average promote the better people
even if not always
okay and you should look for
was it said by
most doctors
or by
one doctor who hasn't practiced for a
long time
and the same
and the same is in
the same is everywhere
uh
yes there are phd in mathematic people
with a phd in mathematics who who who
shouldn't have gotten their phd
yes there are people brilliant people
with bro who did real brilliant phd phds
in mathematics and 10 years later
uh lost their mind and are
speaking nonsense
i mean
it's
there is no look at this certificate and
if somebody has the certificate then
then they're
trustworthy ashley ship wants to know is
there a connection between not theory
and protein folding
and is it possible to use
well if so is it possible to use the
artificial intelligence research that
has been done on protein folding to
inform knot theory
there is a connection between protein
folding and between dna and stuff like
that
in in not theory
uh people
it's not very strong
like in general
uh
he
people like to say things about it but
the actual research at least my own
research is very different
from um
what you would end up doing with
in biology of uh
of dnas or or proteins
by the way
uh
uh
in some sense uh
dna
the the study or
okay
so
dna molecules are really really really
really long strings
chromosomes
are really really really really really
long strings
namely they are of length billions
or the ratio of their length to their
width is billions
okay because they have billions um
uh amino acids along them all right
and um
so so you know if you were to make it
out of probe
it would be
very very very thin rope which is very
very long
but yet this rope is compressed into a
tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny regions
so they get knotted
and
even your experience from a much smaller
knot so here's an electric cable if you
have a little bit of an experience with
letting loose of cables not tying them
nightly
nicely as i tied this yeah if you let it
loose it gets melted
and it it's it's very it's nearly
impossible to untie
uh
chromosomes are much worse they're much
much much longer
in in relative terms and they get
cramped into tiny tiny tiny spaces so
how come they don't get knotted
and if they do get knotted
how come
uh
during various uh
uh
parts of the life of a cell so when when
when cells um
uh split
uh they split they somehow managed to
untie themselves and disconnect
so how how is it happening so there must
be some
huge brain inside every cell
uh that can untangle knots which are
much much much much much more
complicated
uh than the knots that uh
that you can untie
or you know the notes that you take
hours to untie with sometimes
okay
so there must be something there
and this and there is something there
and there are enzymes
that actually uh you know so
when when uh
uh
dna molecules
need to are not to untangle
there are enzymes that allow one
molecule to pass through the other so
basically you want to pass one string
through another so that they will come
to position there are enzymes that cut
this one temporarily it gets cut it
passes to the other side and it gets
reconnected
so in a sense
uh
biology
invented anti-nautiorianza
enzymes
and and they are
necessary because of not theory
because if there were nots you wouldn't
be able to divide cells
uh
so so so so so biology invented some
some anti-node theory enzymes that allow
things to pass through each other that
nullify not theory so in some sense the
most interesting not theory that happens
in biology is somehow anti-node theory
that's a lovely story but in practice
there isn't much
jack desart wants to know is math a
human construct that we've devised to
better understand the universe or is
math a set of universal unchanging
principles i'm a human how would i know
about um
you know how non-humans would say math
or how you know i
i don't know
but
this said
i mean i don't want to answer the
philosophical question but i want to
answer some there is some practical
things that comes out of it
every bit of math
so you know pick up a math book
here
every bit of math in this book
and not just this i mean every bit of
math in every book
was created by a human
ah
that's a good thing to remember it means
that there are no miracles
it means that
uh
you know when you see a proof
and you have no
idea where could it come from
well you have no idea but somebody had
this idea and you may be able to find it
so
it's often extremely instructive
to try to reverse engineer somehow
not just understand the proof but
understand how
humans with all their failures could
have found them
so
so it's actually useful to know that
math was entirely created by humans at
the end
do you think we don't spend enough time
in books talking about the missteps so
for example here's how the person
arrived at this proof they originally
thought of it like so this didn't work
or would that just bloat the book
unnecessarily
it would probably bloat the book
but
but motivation should be there
[Music]
and when i say motivate okay so
so some story is
should be told
like when you present
a proof
there should always be some plausible
discovery story how could this proof
have been found
it doesn't have to be a a historically
accurate
uh story
but but but but there has to be some
story explaining that this proof could
have been found by humans it wasn't
created by some
supernatural entity
this question
cx770 asks does he believe in the
concept of god
no
okay this one's a tangential question
bill mcgonicle asks ramanujan said that
he learned from his goddess
others suggest well ramona john said
that he learned from his goddess by
meditating and praying or came to him in
dreams some of his
formulas esoteric formulas what does
professor draw barnetten make of this
can speak from ramanu for ramanujan
i tend to be a
rationalist
uh
atheist
uh
no miracles
if i think hard about something i either
solve it or don't but there's there's no
there are no miracles in business
another question this one this is my
question are there some relatively
elementary concepts that you've recently
had a new insight on so for example my i
don't know if you know my brother
sebastian he's a professor at u of t as
well in math finance he was telling me
kurt you know only recently maybe last
year i thought i realized oh the
triangle inequality is actually about a
triangle he would only just use the
formula
also recently okay the jacobian
determinant the jaycobian is actually
like
it's like a linear map of of what is
that point
doing
close instead of just okay think of it
as an abstraction of slopes and stuff
yeah so do you have an example
sorry of what of things that i've only
recently understood no no no of
something you have understood you've
used before but then maybe you've come
to a different understanding of you and
you say oh that's an interesting way of
thinking about it i didn't see that
before
it happens all the time well i wish it
would have happened all the times when
it happens it's a great day not all day
is a great day but there is the
occasional great day
uh
you know every time you learn some
something has
a higher meaning it's it's or more
meaning than you thought it's great news
it happens all the time in the life in
the professional life of a
scientist
though not every day
okay
[Music]
well
uh
i'll give you an example which somehow
which i think also partially involves
you so um
a few years ago i was asked to give a
10 minutes talk or something
uh to a i'm
i don't even remember what was the event
but you were there
oh you remember that
mentorship event or something like that
i don't remember that's what that was
that's right and i thought what would i
talk about and i
well okay the truth is that i have some
list of uh
ready-made topics that i can talk about
you know
if you ask me to talk in front of high
school students i sort of have a number
of topics that are ready okay
uh but nothing really fit
and also sometimes i i get bored of
myself
so i have to occasionally add something
so i said okay why don't i talk about a
prisoner's dilemma
and um
so i i mentioned the prisoner's dilemma
in five minutes or so
and it's a very light map right it's
hardly math it's so light that it's
hardly math
but then i realized that it's that it
has a
profound i i guess the economists have
always understood that
they always thought it was important but
i realized it only relatively recently
so that was what is it three four years
ago
uh i only then understood how
profoundly
important it is
so
you know
the prisoner's dilemma is some numerical
example
where
you have
two sides two people a and b
and they can choose whether to
cooperate or
betray each one chooses independently
whether to cooperate with the other or
betray the other
and if you look at the numbers
each one no matter what the other does
would prefer to betray
and as a result both of them would
betray
and the overall outcome is worse to both
of them again i'm not describing the
whole thing i'm not telling the numbers
i'm just saying
there is this situation where if each
one acts selfishly
it's worth for it's worse for both
and
well
it has huge philosophical implications
you know there is a whole a whole um
uh
political class
that believes
that people should be acting selfishly
because if each one acts selfishly it's
actually for the best of the
uh
for
better for everyone
that's somehow the foundation of the
belief in free markets
uh so
uh uh
so so yes i am actually still a great
believer in free markets
i actually still greatly believe that
free markets are a good thing
but there is a little asterisk
sorry that's not duality that's an
asterisk so there is a little asterisk
asterisk and the asterisk says
provided somebody arranges so that free
markets when each one acts selfishly
you will not be led into prisoners
dilemma
dilemmas you will be
you will be you'll be you'll stay out
and
uh and your selfish acts will actually
benefit
the overall good so i mean this asterisk
here is the prisoner's dilemma
ah sorry i well okay yes yes yes i get
it anyway uh
and you think it's a small asterisk but
the more you think about it you realize
it's actually a huge asterisk
it completely changes the picture
and it's much much much more common
you think of it as an esoteric example
but then you realize that it's
everywhere
so it's actually a very very big
asterisk
and
um
i think i realized it relatively
recently
i'm honored that you remember that i
didn't think that uh i'm honored to even
be a footnote in your memory
oh don't be silly
okay
what have you applied also this question
comes from harinav harinavis harinivis
sorry harinivis p asks has drawer
applied the principles of mathematics to
some other domain of his life
like let's give an example of a
non-trivial example
well okay i mean
i can give two answers okay
one answer is uh well i don't know if
it's the principles of mathematics but
you know
uh
people once uh
uh
there was a claim going on and it's been
going around and in fact it's still
going around
uh that uh
you that the bible contains predictions
in code
so if you read the bible with letter
skips if you read every tenth letter
you will occasionally find a word
that's not surprising
but the claim was that these words
where
that that it actually happens more than
statistics would
uh predict and that these words have
messages in them
and uh
and there was a group of people in
jerusalem
that
published a paper and in fact it passed
peer review
uh but so so they published a paper
in which they
uh
supposedly proved this fact
they did careful statistical analysis
again carefully in quotes
uh
and and and and and showed that the
effect was real
and therefore
the bible uh must have been written by
god
because no human could have put this
information into the bible
it's information information that was
not did not even exist at the time that
the bible was written
and therefore in prayer and so so god
wrote the bible
uh
furthermore it's the hebrew bible uh so
there is a god and that god loves hebrew
more than she loves japanese i
understand yeah uh you know this would
be the greatest discovery in if it was
true it would have been the greatest
discovery in the history of science and
i'm not kidding
right i mean there's no longer an
argument between atheism and tazin
pays and wins
my role was to debunk this
is this real life or not
i don't know i me and a group of people
read critically these assertions that go
that were good enough that they passed
peer review
in a respectable journal and we found
gaps
and the gaps are well we're good enough
that the same peer-reviewed journal
accepted our paper too
okay so you know in some sense my role
was negative right what could have been
the greatest discovery in the history of
science a proof that there is god and
it's the hebrew god
uh
was debunked maybe it's a negative
discovery but
well i mean even maybe my effect well my
part was negative i've killed a great
discovery but that's also a
a valuable thing to do i mean to kill a
uh the other thing is uh
otherwise
mathematics plays an extremely limited
role in my life
other than my professional life if you
ex if you cut out
uh the eight hours a day that i work on
mathematics mathematics has no role in
my life or hardly any role so i mean you
do and in fact also almost no role in
your life so basically
you know if you um
you give change in restaurants you uh so
so or in when shops sorry you add 15
percent
tip
that's about the math you need in real
life
multiplication you don't need
but
but if you're a carpenter you probably
need it
right you need to
tiles or you know if you're a trade
person you need to tile a certain room
this the room is five by six right how
many tiles do you need so multiplication
trade people need but but but but people
like me don't need
um
trigonometry well maybe architect nitric
architecture trigonometry some parts of
engineering and we get more and more
esoteric
need higher and higher mathematics
without the very high mathematics
without general relativity
gps satellites wouldn't work so in some
sense we use mathematics every day
but we're not the engineers who design
gps city live seat satellites gps
satellites were designed by a group of
a very small group of people somewhere
in some
you know
design bureau
and they use high-level mathematics so
so so but my real life
high level mathematics
is almost nothing
except once sorry the bible codes and
another time
and i've given talks with this title
so uh the title was uh the
hardest
uh
mathematics
uh i've
uh
ever
really
yeah
and if you google this title probably
you'll be able to find a video of that
talk
and you'll find that one time
where
it was actually in my professional life
but in a meta way
so not my research but something about
how to present my research i ended up
using a very high level mathematics
hyperbolic geometry in fact
so one time it happened anyway what was
your next question
why does it take 360 pages of abstruse
symbols to prove that one plus one
equals two
occam's razor says we can cut this we
can just say one plus one equals two
because every single last one of us
believes it does
so what do you make of that why is it so
complex to prove something simple like
one plus one equals two do we even need
that
and this question comes from roy dobson
so
uh
let me answer the
let me answer a different question
uh you know so one plus one equals two
so the the reference is probably to uh
work of uh russell
um
basically
if your axiom system is
very very very basic
and
um
and very very um
primitive in a way very very
simple-minded and you want your axiom
system to be very very very basic
then it might be that even proving one
plus one equal to would be difficult
but it will be a part of the build up
and later you will be uh
proving harder things and
but the truth is it's silly okay but let
me give you an another example okay so
uh you know there is the intermediate
value theorem
the intermediate value theorem says uh
that if you have a function
continuous function so if f is
continuous
and it's negative here and positive here
then at some point it crosses zero
uh we teach it in week seven
maybe i don't know of undergraduate
calculus maybe it's just week five or
maybe it's week nine i don't remember
okay
you can ask
this is so idiotic
right
why
why does it take five or seven weeks to
prove the obvious that if you go
continuously from here to here you'll be
crossing zero
and the answer
is that when you prove the intermediate
value theorem
you are not actually proving the
intermediate value theorem
you are actually testing
your definition of continuity
you're testing
your abstract setup
you're testing your abstract setup your
your language you're testing
uh
you know the the machinery of for every
epsilon there exists a delta such that
blah blah blah if you could not prove
the intermediate value theorem
you'd be rejecting the abstract system
not the intermediate value theorem you'd
be rejecting this not that
so
the seven weeks were not about the
intermediate value theorem they were
about
this for every epsilon there exists
delta and then you can ask
what's for every epsilon there exists
delta for why do we need this well we
don't need it to prove the intermediate
value theorem the intermediate value
theorem was testing this
what do we need it for
and the answer is well there are later
things
like
uh e to the x is equal to sum of x to
the n divided by n factorial
which is this by the way looks innocent
and people think they understand it but
it's actually a miracle
and this miracle depends on well it
doesn't depend but i mean there are
maybe other ways to reach there but but
but you you will believe this miracle
miracle after you've understood this
system
so
uh so the answer is uh in a way we
didn't go from
uh
uh
here to here
to here
but more like this was known it
validated this and then uh we could use
it to do other things
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you